e
go
okay good morning everybody I'll open up
the uh I forgot my gavel but I guess I
don't know if I need it um open up the
exec session um a couple of housekeeping
uh so I will not be scheduling anything
for next week uh historically I I um I
don't take I don't like to do Senate
bills until after crossover that way I
know all the bills that we have and of
course I would then organiz oriz them by
type so that they our hearings are
organized and in this case I have to you
know consult with the senator to make
sure the senator is able to come over
and be here when that we'll be
introducing those
bills um last night I was going through
the bills and realized that the sheet
that we normally would use the
scheduling sheet um I got down to the
bottom and I said I feel like I'm
missing something um and so so I ended
up um well now that now all a sudden
most of them are
here so we'll work from this
sheet assuming that what's in front of
everybody so that's one one that says
revised at the top so maybe I didn't
have the right revisal when I did it I
don't know what happened
so
okay so first bill House Bill
1033 related to the advertising a
nominal dimensions of lumber
representative spear seconded by
representative
Ammon moves um inexpedient to legislate
is there any discussion on the motion of
any of in expedient to
legislate see
none no you don't don't need to feel
compelling
any I I think the the industry the
lumber industry indicated
that the uh the the method that we
currently use for uh determining the
size of lumber width and depth is
something that they base their entire
sales worldwide and so it's not it's not
something that can be
changed and right it's an industry
standard I'm sorry I should put that
name word in there great is there any
discussion on the motion of ining spe to
legislate see on the cler will call the
role representative Ammon yes on itl
yes Co
yes
yes W yes burrow yes Herbert yes
yes yes fear yes rung yes
Casey yes is it Casey Carri Carri like a
something Irish Truck Yeah like a
carrye
yes
okay alth those 17 because we're missing
collabro right so that' be post and
we're missing post post is here no post
missing
fair enough I wouldn't sit next to him
smart here post is here yes so that
would be 17 that's correct because we're
now because we're we're missing because
because Vincent is no longer on the
committee and and and then calabra is
the missing
person no grass is being
replaced okay the motion carries the 17
to zip all those in favor of placing it
on the consent Calendar please say I
unanimously
oh all right
so well it should be
Mark um to
missing car right so and Sullivan's
missing
five keep an eye on that one do the
same okay we're good all
right on to 1071 right to
repair certain educational technology
representative spear second by
representative hunt moves inexpedient to
legislate is there any discussion on the
motion
do you want me to say something no I
okay okay we've heard it all we've heard
it all and you know again emphasize this
is the power of the fact that we do
everything by subit right and so so
every issue has gotten well thrashed out
and
subcommittee okay so the motion is
inexpedient to legislate is the question
clear all right the clerk will call the
RO
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes a yes belli yes taxton yes
Walsh yes fos yes Herbert yes clerk yes
M
yes Gibbs yes spear yes rung yes car yes
Z okay all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I those
oppose so moved
unanimously okay uh next up House Bill
1090 repealing require where I get
relative repealing the requirement to
register Farm's Market as a trade
name okay um the sponsored asked us to
kill this bill so I move uh inexpedient
to to legislate unless somebody else
would like to do it
no okay I'll second and second by
representative
buum okay any discussion on inexpedient
to
legislate see none the clerk will call
the
role all right representative Ammon yes
pusic yes poost yes Cole yes migil yes
yes pelli
yes taxton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert
yes clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Rong yes Carrie yes and chairman hunt
yes 17 Z okay the motion passes 17 zip
all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so moved
unanimously next up uh relative to
creating a committee to study the
protection of business operators against
requests to accommodate customers with
fraudulent or untrained service animals
uh representative Cole second by
representative moves Burrows moves uh in
term
burrow any discussion on the motion of
of interim
study seeing none the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes Mig yes pelli yes
yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes Clark yes maer yes Gibbs yes spear
yes rung yes Carrie yes and chairman
hunt yes 17 zip okay um all the 17 zip
all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I those
opposed it's moved
unanimously so how are we doing Chris
how are we doing on the uh Amendment for
it do we know have we heard back
from yeah isn't that the isn't that the
one no no that's no that one's a
different one I'm sorry you're right
you're right yeah no okay right now I
now okay yeah this is the one I'm
supposed to be making the motion okay
okay uh relative requirements for sewage
Disposal Systems information to be
disclosed during the real estate
transactions uh House Bill
1144 um I move uh to pass and seconded
by representative spear what I had in I
guess in
committee this is the one this is the
one the restaurant one this is when
you're doing a commercial property not
this is not
residential this is the commercial one
and they were how many so this one this
one had no opposition and the depart
came in and wanted us to pass
it okay any other discussion on the
motion like to
pass all right seeing none the clerk
will call the
r representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes MCU yes pelli yes
daxon yes Walsh yes barrows yes Herbert
yes clerk yes maer yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Rong yes Carrie yes
chairman hunt yes
170 okay the motion pass 17 to zip all
those in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
move unanimously okay now this is the
other one this is the restaurant one
yeah
and so this one I have is itl yeah did I
get him confused I hope not I think it
is it it was waiting for
uh
new new regulations I think it was all
about the building codes
again you're doing building regulation
right this is the one we already take we
took care of with a bill last year y
that's right that's right so it was so
we didn't need didn't need this bill
okay so uh representative hunt second
representative spear moves inexpedient
to
legislate okay it's the motion clear the
role all
right representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maer yes Gibbs
yes spear yes rung yes case carry yes 17
to zero okay motion carries to vote 17
to zip um all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I those
opposed so moved
1243 uh revising the laws relative to
retail installment sales and Motor
Vehicles okay this one I think
is okay yeah this one's ought to pass on
myself it's not to pass ought to pass on
the
amendment okay the motion clear uh the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes yes maer yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Rong yes and Carrie
yes and chairman hunt yes 17 zero on
Amendment okay motion is 17 to zip all
those in favor placing oh no a to pass
as amended
right get ahead of myself here okay any
discussion on the motion about to pass
as
role all right yeah M leer and myself
right you're okay maer you okay with
writing the blur for this one sure
okay I'm sure the auto dealers would be
help helpful
direct for you I don't see them in the
room where Stand Down the
room oh are you're I'm sorry I did not
know
that okay okay cck call the rooll a to
amended representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes yes pachelli yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs yes
spear
yes rung yes Carrie yes chairman hunt
yes 17
Z okay all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I those
opposed so move
unanimously okay
1275 relative to requiring notice to
Consumers of vehicles that require
repair solely through a dealership and
contain proprietary
information
okay represent Speer second by
legislate okay any discussion on the
itl oh my you know that's $5 to our
better go check
mine
okay uh all right the clerk will call
them uh the role on inexpedient to
legislate on
1275 representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
lurk yes
Mair
yes Gibbs yes spear yes rung yes Carrie
yes 17 to zero uh motion carries vote 17
to zip um all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so move
damous okay now 1320 we do we have the
1320 Mr chair point of order um on the
last bill does the FN require it to be
on the regular calendar no FN means that
the uh fiscal note was issued okay okay
and in this case the fiscal Noe was said
nothing okay didn't say anything so the
only time that you you theoretically
need to have it on the regular calendar
is if there is an actual
appropriation
ironically the vast majority of bills
that we get even if they did have an
appropriation it's not in the bill but
it has to go to finance and then they
make the appropriation so ironically
even though that may be true that the
appropriation is appropriate that it it
it usually we we never actually see it
so but in this case uh this case there
was no appropriation for the bill so
so it's in the
folder
uhhuh so theoretically I like I I was
thinking about this last night that I
don't have to have the subcommittee in
other words the subcommittee could be
waved off um and it was just that so I'm
going to I'm going assuming that I want
to get past this amendment around now
and assuming that nobody has a problem
with it and everybody's ready to vote
for it then we don't need to have the
subcommittee
like you know that I think that's that's
a that's a hearing that's not even a
subcommittee subcommittees are a little
Loosey gooy but that's true I could do
that anyways okay so you're saying I
have it here yeah 1320 you see it right
amendment and I'm passing around and so
everybody has a chance to look at the
amendment anyways because you're going
to have to see it now and assuming if if
there nobody has a problem then we can
just go ahead and exec it if there is a
problem then we will uh not take it up
and wait until U the subcommittee meets
so
you can vote no if you want to vote if
you want to vote no that's fine it won't
feelings
two
five
eight
great yep that looks pretty good looks
job Mr chairman yes it looks like it's
exactly what you said we were going to
actually I did see something
new and it's on line
five and that is just because uh they
are a model efficiency that they did say
by the way we're we're
adding flood and the only other thing as
I said is after we heard uh yesterday is
that um pasas is going to show up and so
if the P shows up and if they had just
put it right if they had it uh also the
same or in a Roman
numeral uh if they're like you know if
it's I don't know where where they'll
end up putting P but if there is a
problem with P then um enroll bills will
take care of that problem to get them
matched
up uh having once served on the chair as
chair of legislative Administration I
know how that works okay so if everybody
okay with 1320 yep except
ran I will play nice in the sandbox okay
the
sandbox so this is a adoption of the
okay so this is uh Au representative
hunt second by representative bullo
1247 all right okay and any discussion
on the
amendment good job seeing none the clerk
will call the role
just for the
subcommittee oh no this is we're bagging
the subcomittee we don't need a sub I
think we'll have it then okay but are
just the subcommittee members voting on
this no this is committee okay got it
get getting here done uh representative
Ammon yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes beu
yes pelli yes Daxton Walsh yes burrow
yes Herbert yes clerk yes maer
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Rong yes Carrie
yes chairman hunt yes 17 Z on the
amendment okay motion now represent hunt
second by represent buo the moves ought
to pass as amended is there any
motion seeing none the clerk will call
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes MC yes melli yes Daxton
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes M yes Gibbs
yes spear yes rung yes Terry yes chamman
hunt
Z all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
unanimously okay good job all
right all right next up uh House Bill
1346 relative to food service at Bed and
Breakfast
what do we have for that one yeah
spear uh inexpedient represented spear
inexpedient legislate second by
representative
hunt you really wanted to like write a
lot of reports that's
great
itl
okay right any discussion on the motion
of inexpedient to
legislate seeing none the clerk will
call the role representative Ammon yes
pusk yes po yes Cole yes M yes melli yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes Maier
yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Rong yes Carrie yes shamman
170 okay motion carries uh unanimously
all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so mooved
unanimously okay next up uh House Bill
13 uh 95 relative to home heating oil
contracts Okay so
40 question
yes okay um I believe the sponsor
emailed amendments is it too late to
consider those amendments yes which Bill
are we talking about 13 1395 is
there yeah we're not going not sure how
he I'm not sure what the process would
be no we're all set thank you we're all
set you okay well first I need to I'm
going to place the motion but all right
so I have
1395 interim study representative Cole
and second by representative
Burrows and we're open for discussion
representative Spar uh we did get the
two amendments from uh is this this is
it there's two different ones there
right did the the you're you're talking
about the one where the guy it was the
pricing
well let me put it this
officially at an exec session someone
can as to bring up an amendment yes okay
um but as a control freak chairman um
you know that I would order that any
amendment that shows up then I would say
no we won't take action we would then
send it back to subcommittee and have
the subcommittee work it out so that by
the time so that that that can be
resolved so um if somebody were to show
up with a with an amendment in while
we're executing um you know normally
other committees do thrash it out
committees as a whole and you know and I
woe the day that I
happens under my guidance that I would I
would prefer to send it to subcommittee
and have it you know worked out thrashed
out because I just think it's more
productive when you have a small group
of people who are focused I just want
understand your process thank you for
explain to clarify yes um I just want to
understand it so are you saying because
they emailed it we're not taking it up
no we did subcommittee actually was
aware of the amendment yeah when the
subcommittee and the sub committee made
the decision not to not to address it
because he he he the the feeling of the
subcommittee was it wasn't really
resolving okay the problem okay great
thanks um an amendment can be brought to
the floor and Amendment could always
even on session date y right and you
could say it's because that mean nasty
but but like I said that my process that
is that I I when we get to exec session
I that we've already thrashed it out
that we're not going to take everybody's
time up on on something that that is an
issue that really if and and this one in
particular this particular Bill really
does need some serious hard thinking
about how we're going to address this
problem and do it right so
representative run who welcome to the
Congress committee thank you thank you
um so is the motion in terms study stud
oh okay thank you so we're going to work
on it we're we we we're definitely not
we're not ignoring it it's just that
it's something that's going to take some
time and really think it through and how
we can do it do it right I really
appreciate the committee doing that
because if you remember from the public
hearing the assistant the senior
Assistant Attorney General supported
this bill with two very minor changes
and you know this industry is one of the
top three I think said that they
received complaints upon and even though
they are those complaints are centered
around one company that company H has or
had the largest market share and there's
nothing in this bill that specifies that
company so I think it does provide
protection for the little guys that send
us here you know the the the little
grandmas that aren't going to fight a
big company they're just going to pay
the extra fee or wait to change
suppliers so I I think it's a very
important bill um I was really you know
hoping to go Gang Busters to try to get
an amendment but I'm very I I I'm
satisfied with the interm study and I
think we could work closely with the
with attorney uh Garrett and the
consumer protection um Bureau to to Hash
okay okay uh representative spear made
no Co Cole and bur Cole and burough I'm
sorry so used to sings Bear
right interim study is the the pending
motion okay is the question clear the
clerk will call the role representative
Ammon yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes M
yes pelli yes Daxton yes Walsh yes buros
yes Herbert yes clerk yes MCL
yes Gibbs yes spe here yes Rong yes
Carrie yes and chairman hunt yes
170 okay vote is 17 zip all those in
favor of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay 1430 relative to
electric rates approved by the Public
Utilities Commission for residential
condominium
properties this was the bill that was
commercial rates for the
yes correct right talking about the pool
so I I have myself anybody else like to
make the motion or represent spe you'll
you what would you
like would you want to write the
blurb okay all right representative H
second by representative Spear and
what's the motion the motion is
inexpedient to legislate all
right yeah this this this bill would
open incredible can of worms if we were
to pass it because of the common space
that are inside condos and common spaces
are in many rental situations so all
right this is on itl in expedient to
legislate is the question clear the
clerk will call the role representative
Ammon yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes M
yes belli yes taxton yes Walsh yes
burrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes M yes Gibbs yes speier yes rung yes
yes 17 vot 17 is zip all those in favor
of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so moveed
damous okay House Bill
uh right so I'll I'll make the motion
and you'll second it or you want to rate
the motion on this one you want to write
the blur on this one okay all right
representative spear second by
representative hunt um 1491 prohibiting
the repricing of heating fuel subsequent
to a concluded
you yes you were just on account of I
just have to do due diligence on stuff
we did get two amendments on this and so
I called a couple of fuel suppliers this
is the one I called a couple of fuel
suppliers as the case was presented to
us in the the cases where I called the
fuel suppliers they said they would not
deliver fuel to a house that they had
not inspected and established a cont
contract even if it's a pay as you go
corre so they had to have a contract and
in that contract it would have said when
you use a credit
card you're reserving the right to get
the fuel but you're not committed to the
price you still have to pay the price on
the day that they pick it up I guess in
Boston I guess is where they pick this
the the fuel oil up so the case that was
described to us is not a case anybody
seems to recognize as being something
that should be handled any different
than they handle any other case so I
think the itl is the right motion right
and and if they really wanted to be
locking in the price they can do a pre-
buby then they could do the pre- buby
and that's what they I was told by these
these suppliers right and if in the
worst comes worst case for the state if
you're not happy with the arrangement
with your propane dealer there's plenty
of other propane dealers available that
you can do business with except if you
have your tank buried then it's another
story then have to be like me and own my
own tank right pay the two grand and own
your own tank okay motions in expedient
motion okay the clerk will call the role
representative Ammon yes pusk yes poost
yes Cole yes migu yes pachelli yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes yes clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs
yes
yes 17 Z okay the vote uh carries it's
17 is it all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I those
opposed so move
damous okay house bill 1498 establishing
a a state short-term rental
registry representative macul second by
representative hunt and I did register
as a as a um a short-term renter okay
legislate any discussion on the motion
legislate
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes
taxton yes Walsh yes fos yes Herbert yes
Clark yes maer yes Gibbs yes spear yes
rung yes Carrie yes jamman hunt yes 17
Z okay vote carries 17 zip all those in
favor of putting on the consent Calendar
please say I those opposed so moved
unanimously hunt mle and hunt Okay House
Bill 1635 relative to the definition of
short-term rental represented immac
seconded by represent of hunt who did
file that he has a conflict um moves uh
in speing to
motion I would say that um I really did
was hoping that we could do a Statewide
registry to try to solve this problem
but neither side wants to wants to
negotiate or settle this issue at this
point because there are a lot of court
cases are still you know cases are still
going on and so it's it's an unsettled
issue in in terms of legality uh so at
this point everybody just assume we not
we the legislature not weigh in
yet
okay uh the clerk will call the role on
inexpedient to legisl right
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yeah M yes pelli yes taxton yes
Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes clerk
yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes Rong yes
Carrie yes chairman hunt yes 17 Z okay
what 17 is zip all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously
okay do the same thing here with
1241 that if assuming that everyone is
happy we will
just exact this bill and have it and the
subcommittee BS
to
yeah okay so need to say this bill has
been
amended uh a couple of times uh to
address uh issues Ure that we were not
weighing in on crypto
technology uh and uh that it should not
have any effect on
cryptocurrency but there will be
language in here that talks about them
statute okay
Mr chairman yes represent speak does
this amendment take care of all the
other little amendments all the other
little amendments all rolled on into one
one
Amendment
okay all right so um I move ought to
1245 any discussion excuse me I move and
and this is banking so
who's okay well represent Ammon second
yeah not sure representative Urban would
want a
second is it okay so ought to Ammon
yeah okay ought to pass on the amendment
any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pachelli yes Aon
no Clark yes mclair yes Gibbs yes spear
yes rung yes Carrie yes chairman hunt
yes 16 to one okay now representative am
moves
otpa
yeah and representative Ammon will speak
to his
motion so uh as amended um I think it's
a good example of our departments being
business friendly they made
accommodations for uh payroll payroll
providers and they they're preserving an
advantage uh that New Hampshire has in a
virtual currency that we had since 2017
so uh I think this is a a good move
forward and we're adopting language that
other states are
adopting okay any other discussion on
the motion about to pass as amended
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes yes pachelli yes
Daxton yes Walsh
yes Barrow yes Herbert
no clerk yes backler
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Rong yes Carrie
yes chairman hunt yes
161 okay uh representative Herbert are
you okay with putting this on the
consent calendar yes okay all those in
favor with consent please say I I those
unanimously okay House Bill 1129
relative to the author to vote by proxy
Association
[Music]
and I have me again anybody else want to
do condos I will you want to do that
thank you all right representative bullo
hunt moves uh ought to pass on the
amendment
number we have the amendment
number
thank you 0878 0
0878 then forget about the
side oh 871
0871 got it like could I'm sure it's in
okay so no there was multiple amendments
to this do we are we did you end up
doing
one now it
says what build number we doing all
right I had the wrong build
number
right it is
0871 is correct
okay does everybody
justly
explain
uh um well the one thing I know because
we've had this issue for many years
talking about how we're going to U help
condos with proxy voting the key element
we're doing here is that the actual
proxy ballot will be very much like let
say the ballot you get when you vote on
proxies for your for stock companies it
is specific to the actual motion so the
ones we've always saw before was that
another condo owner would hold the proxy
for somebody else and that always seemed
problematic that and so that this way
that the actual voting issue is in hand
at ahead of time everybody knows it
everybody knows what you know in terms
of what they're voting yes or no on and
um and so that seems to resolve the
issue once or for all it's not a blanket
it's not a blanket proxy
exactly okay any discussion on the
motion of ought to pass on the
amendment right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes pelli
yes Daxton Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs yes spear
yes
170 okay motion carries 17 is zip um all
those in favor pleasing no we all to
pass as amended is
representative
Amon condo condo condo right okay okay
all right right so um
uh yeah yeah no it's bullo Y
bullo and HT and Hunt is second moves
ought to pass on the amendment any
discussion on the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
host yes Cole yes M yes melli yes Z
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maer
yes Gibbs yes spear yes rung yes Carrie
yes Jim hunt yes 170 okay motion carries
a vote of 17 is zip all those in favor
of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so move
6 and 1296 has an
amendment
we oh yeah the amendment is the
effective
date okay that was it you have the
go the one for the date was 1133
H
113 okay
so uh representative hunt representative
hunt seconded by representative Burrows
moves ought to pass on the
amendment any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
host yes Cole yes MCU yes belli yes
Daxton Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs yes spear yes
rung yes Carrie yes chairman hunt yes 17
to zero okay the motion is now on to
pass as amended is there any discussion
on the motion I'd like to move it oh you
want to move it I want to move okay
burrow well
so uh just just to remind everybody that
you know what
even what this bill does is that it says
be we we already have the statute you
know in law that mography are are you
get a free MOG women get can have a free
mogy every every year and that was an
issue at one point time because it used
to be like a year and a day and so that
was problematic but we solved it and to
annual annually um and what this says is
that if there is a need for the uh
secondary diagnostic survey then then
that too will also be
free that's great
so nothing for real it said but but
going forward that the year next year if
it turns out negative you're going going
forward you don't you don't get to keep
that it's the same it's the same for you
still got to get the regular mography
right you have to you have to have the
Fe first before you can get the free one
free yep great okay great clerk will
call the role on a to pass as
amended representative Ammon yes pusk
yes poost yes Cole yes MC yes pelli yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes Mair yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Rong yes Carrie yes chairman hunt
zero all those in favor of placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
yes
okay well actually they're all rolled
now yep so this is another good thing
around
we'll
more
okay um first up is the uh oop
pass uh on the
1365 1243 excuse
me yeah 1243 on the
amendment who would like to make
representative hunt second by
representative bur moves to pass on the
amendment any discussion on the
amendment see none the clerk will call
the
role
um actually I have a question oh okay
sorry um it doesn't say here in the
amendment but I think in the original
bill it does say that the the position
or
the person the customer patient
patient they have the right to correct
yes that's actually in the original
that's in the original
bill
okay clerk will call the role on ought
to pass on the
amendment representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Nicole yes MC yes belli yes
baxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes Gibbs yes spear yes rung
yes Carrie yes Jim hunt
yes 17 to zero on the
amendment did I do this
wrong oh yes okay that's right that's
right okay so
um okay the motion now is ought to pass
as amended representative Ammon second
by representative burrow moves ought to
pass unamended and is there any
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the
role
representative Ammon yes pusk yes poost
yes Cole yes M
no pelli yes
daxon Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maclir yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Rong yes Carrie yes chairman hunt
yes 161 16 to one we'll leave that on
the regular calendar because representa
Miku will be doing a Minority Report so
GNA get up on the floor yes you're not
going to florify you just he just wants
to have his Minority Report but he can't
put a Minority Report and have it on
consent okay yeah so that was 16 to one
16 to one is
correct
okay okay next one I have is uh house
on
five
for
okay uh representative
pusc seconded by representative
burough moves ought to pass on the
0998 um so basically this this is sort
of a housekeeping measure but we it of
of things that had come to my attention
over the uh the year and people say well
we need to do this we need that we got
to fix this problem fix that problem um
the problems uh occurred um a was the
um these Hookah Hookah
establishments um were operating under a
cigar bar statue and but they they
weren't necessarily smoking cigar
they were're doing hookas so we're just
clarifying that uh that they that a
cigar bar can include a hookah
um the distill yeah it's licensed to
distill um in terms of uh the quantities
and then we have a scaled up pricing uh
for their
licensing and
hookah okay so
her so what we're doing is we're just
creating um a two different uh a tier
system when it comes to distilling so in
terms of license so this was designed to
uh reduce the am I got this right Dan no
maybe uh yeah that first section six of
the bill oh I'm thinking of there's
other sections because this is six yeah
so what was six
for just introduce yourself so everybody
REM deputy chief Danielle Elon New
Hampshire Liquor enforcement um no this
just clarifies that it's if you're
licensed to distill then this paragraph
applies to you because there's also the
home distilling bill in so we wanted to
make sure there was clarification
between the liquor manufacturers that
are licensed to distill versus what's
happening in the home distilling bill so
um it just changes it used to say each
liquor manufacturer distilling and now
it just says license to distill so we
didn't change quantities or anything
like that we just clarify just clar the
licensed liquor Manu like I said this is
housekeeping correct related to the bill
that we passed already that we allowed
to home home license home
so so this is not related to hookah no
that is not a hookah section section
seven of the bill is the hookah which
was the original underlying kind of got
mixed up with because this came in
because the original bill you can see
we're at six section six so there was
one through five right with other
various issues and then this one just
came over the transom in the end and you
know we whether we could we could slip
it in while we were still working on
bills last last fall and and the U ol
asked us
to not try to add one more item to that
to that Christmas tree and to add told
us to add this uh here in committee
which is what we did thank you
okay all right is the motion clear on
this is ought to pass on the amendment
clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes
yes pelli yes taxton Walsh yes buros yes
Herbert yes Clark yes M yes Gibbs yes
spear yes rung yes carry yes chairman
hunt yes 170 on the amendment okay
motion now is uh representative pusc
seconded by representative buroughs
moves ought to pass as amended any
role uh oh you ran out of sheets I ran
out of
sheets oh
on can I just can I make a comment
that's sort of related to the bill I
mean not tone on is it okay I I just was
doing some fat checking when we were um
because there's the the hookah um in
this bill and I read that an hourlong
hookah session is the equivalent of
smoking a 100
cannabis I just thought it was
interesting but that could be cannabis
uh with a bong might yeah you can put
cannabis in there too in a bong would be
be like a hookah wouldn't
it
goes oh yeah right the water well
doesn't a hookah have water in it yeah
yeah so it's the same thing right isn't
a hookah yeah bong is a hookah
right doesn't different device doesn't
doesn't have
that
glass
they they look well one yeah one one is
centuries different
culture okay all right so we're we we're
out to pass as amended as amended okay
right all right motion's made clear oh
sorry we're waiting for you head voting
sheet okay representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes yes Cole yes MC yes belli
yes taxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes clerk yes Mair yes Gibbs yes spear
yes rung yes Carrie yes chairman hunt
yes 17 to zero that's our pass as
amended that is okay now the motion is
ought to pass or is
that okay all right those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I so no opposition unanimous so
moved are we done one more what we
got
okay
1358 uh
contract relative to contract uh
okay
yeah
oh
think
am
correct
okay
this
secret but I would say
yeah they had more fancier fers so you
knew you knew there was a the Chairman's
compe oh you knew it was sacred oh and
we don't get to see those even but chair
even see the chairman holders
anymore
okay so Dan you want don't you just tell
we're good morning Deputy Chief Danielle
Alston New Hampshire L enforcement just
mic so um this amendment deals with
contract um manufactur ining and tenant
manufacturing the most basic explanation
of this is I have a recipe it needs
certain equipment to produce that recipe
you own that equipment so we enter to a
contract together where you are now
going to produce my recipe um in the
past this concept has traditionally uh
been for beverage manufacturers this
manufacturers and and what started was
this some guy from Maine who wanted to
bring it to New Hampshire and that was
add a new twist he had the recipe uh uh
manufacturer in New Hampshire had the
equipment so he wants them to produce
his product in New Hampshire so that's
what's start and then and then we had we
had originally had tenant manufacturing
and contract were separate now we're
trying to pull them all into one statute
and correct so one stop shopping for
shake and
bake the repl the
entire
uh it does it
does is this the buck restaurant or the
U the
restaurant we already took care we
took thank you very much
okay all right so the pending motion is
um so this is representative pusc
seconded by represent buroughs moves
ought to pass on the amendment number
clear clerk will call the
RO representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes MC yes pelli yes
Daxton Walsh yes buros yes Herbert yes
clerk yes ma yes Gibbs yes spear yes
rung yes Carrie yes chairman hunt yes 17
to Z on the amendment okay motion now
with representative pusc second and by
representative Mur moves ought to pass
as amended is there any discussion on
the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
role representative Ammon yes Tusk yes
post yes Cole yes MCU yes pachelli yes
Saxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes mclair yes Gibbs yes
speier yes R yes Carrie yes chairman
hunt yes 17 to
zero all right okay all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so move
damesly okay so now we're
done
um is anybody going to have a problem
not getting their uh uh report committee
report done
today you want to do them at home is
that but you'll get it done today by You
Want It by the end of the day by the end
of the let's let's you know let's let's
say by 5:00 you know you know if you're
going to go home you know you you got to
get it done right and I would also say
that um theoretically um all these
things don't have to be done technically
until tomorrow is our our our day to
report this out so if if there were some
uh catastrophe then I will let you all
know and we would have to come back
after session tomorrow which that would
that would be an awful thing to happen
oh yeah awful awful a so it's not that's
that's hope that will not occur but I I
think we've got them all right I mean
yeah I think I think we got everything I
think I I'd like to thank our secretary
and our researcher for job all done
that's right we couldn't have done it
without you that's for
sure so but otherwise uh we can if
anybody wants to go to tandies for lunch
lunches on
me so thanks our two thanks for our
thanks except for you
right you're out of the
room yeah thank you so much for yeah
thank you for filling
in
again and I guess
yes okay so Senate bills um right now
there are trickling in um and um my my
expectation is not to uh start doing
hearings I know other committees are are
already hot to trot but I'm I'm my at
attitude is to wait until to see what we
have and then try to schedule them as a
group so that that you know makes it
easy for us to um uh have the public
hearing and the groupings will somewhat
be so much as we a is you know we try to
do it by our categories but um our
divisions but a lot is actually driven
by the the Senate sponsor so if if a
senate sponsor has several different
bills and different subjects it's going
to be more the hearing will be about
that that day for the senator uh and
that I have to schedule so it makes it
it's a little different twist in
scheduling bills when I have to have to
work with the senator um but otherwise
um you know I I we've always wait till
till April before we we start those so
you have a couple of days off for next
week next two weeks I guess except there
might
be session
days multiple session days so other
um the exec session is
over question for you um this is the 264
I I started and gave it to him cheed
read I
anybody before s it to you no just s it
to to be model language
we
e
for